Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The discussion had reached its inconclusive end, and the cabinet was about to separate when the quiet, grave tones of Sir Edward Grey's voice were heard, reading a document which had just been brought to him from the Foreign Office. It was the Austrian note to Serbia. We were all very tired, from the Foreign Office. It was the Austrian note to Serbia.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。讨论已经到了无果而终的地步，内阁正准备散去，这时人们听到了爱德华·格雷爵士平静而严肃的声音，他正在宣读一份刚刚从外交部送到他这里的文件。这是奥地利给塞尔维亚的照会。我们都很累了，来自外交部。这是奥地利给塞尔维亚的照会。
We were all very tired, but gradually, as the phrases and sentences followed one another, impressions of a wholly different character began to form in my mind. This note was clearly an ultimatum, but it was an ultimatum such as had never been penned
我们都很累了，但渐渐地，随着那些短语和句子一句接一句地过去，一种完全不同性质的印象开始在我的脑海中形成。这份照会显然是一份最后通牒，但这是一份前所未有的最后通牒
in modern times. As the reading proceeded, it seemed absolutely impossible that any state in the world could accept it, or that any acceptance, however abject, would satisfy the aggressor. The parishes of Fermanagh and Tyrone faded back into the mists and squalls of Ireland, and a strange light began immediately, but by perceptible gradations, to fall and to grow upon the map of Europe. So that, Dominic, was Winston Churchill.
在现代。随着宣读的进行，世界上似乎绝对没有哪个国家能够接受它，也绝对没有任何接受——无论多么卑躬屈膝——能够满足侵略者。弗马纳郡和蒂龙郡的教区重新退入了爱尔兰的迷雾和狂风中，一种奇异的光芒开始立即、但却以清晰可辨的渐进方式，照耀并成长在欧洲地图上。所以，多米尼克，那就是温斯顿·丘吉尔。
Of course. Writing in The World Crisis, which is a book largely about himself, I think, isn't it? It is indeed. On the cabinet meeting held in London, writing in The World Crisis, which is a book largely about himself, I think, isn't it? It is indeed. On the cabinet meeting held in London, the capital of the United Kingdom and of the British Empire on the 24th of July, 1914. And Churchill there is describing the moment that the British foreign secretary and absolutely a personal hero of mine, Sir Edward Gray, reads the Austrian ultimatum to Serbia to his colleagues in the liberal government. And people who heard our last episode, we ended
当然。写在《世界危机》里，那是一本主要关于他自己的书，我想，对吧？的确如此。关于在伦敦召开的内阁会议，写在《世界危机》里，那是一本主要关于他自己的书，我想，对吧？的确如此。关于在伦敦召开的内阁会议，伦敦是大不列颠及大英帝国的首都，时间是1914年7月24日。丘吉尔在那里描述了英国外交大臣——绝对是我的个人偶像——爱德华·格雷爵士向他自由党政府的同僚们宣读奥地利对塞尔维亚的最后通牒的那一刻。听了我们上一集的人，我们的结局是
with the world literally holding its breath. Literally. Literally, as it waited for Serbia's reply to this very, very strict and stern Austrian ultimatum, and with the Russians and the French having pledged that they will hold firm against any sense of ugliness from Austria, and more particularly from Germany. But I think we've had far too much focus on continental powers so far. Right. And I think it's excellent that at last we come to Britain. At last, Tom. At last. So, hello, everybody.
全世界简直都在屏息以待。简直是。简直是，因为它在等待塞尔维亚对这份非常、非常严厉和严正的奥地利最后通牒的回应，而俄国人和法国人已经承诺，他们将坚决抵制来自奥地利、尤其是来自德国的任何丑陋行径。但我觉得到目前为止，我们对欧洲大陆列强的关注实在太多了。没错。而且我认为，我们终于谈到英国，这太棒了。终于，汤姆。终于。那么，大家好。
Yes, we've kept Britain deliberately off stage, haven't we, so far? Because Britain was off stage, actually. Britain hasn't really featured in the deliberations of the various powers, certainly not in the Austrian and German deliberations, and not really. The French and the Russians have talked about binding Britain more closely to them, but how Britain will react is still very ambiguous. And of course, it really, really matters. Britain in 1914 has a much smaller population than it does now, so about 40, 42 million people. And that's even though it has Ireland. Yes, but it is the world's, you know, it's the top nation still just about.
是的，到目前为止，我们故意把英国晾在一边，不是吗？因为英国实际上就被晾在一边。英国并没有真正在各列强的商议中占据重要地位，在奥地利和德意志的商议中绝对没有，也算不上。法国人和俄国人一直在谈论把英国更紧密地捆绑在他们身边，但英国将如何反应仍然非常含糊不清。当然，这真的、真的很重要。1914年的英国人口比现在少得多，大约只有4000到4200万人。尽管它还拥有爱尔兰。是的，但你知道，它仍然勉强算是世界第一大国。
It's obviously was the world's first industrial nation and it's still in the top two or three in most sort of indices. It has the world's largest empire, 400 million people, a quarter of the globe. And it has the world's greatest navy by far, but crucially only a very, very small army. So although the British army have fought battles in the previous decades, they have generally been against Zulus, Boers, Afghans, Sudanese, and so on. But they have picked up khaki, haven't they, as a result of their wars against the Boers? And there's a sense in which actually the British probably have fought more wars than
它显然是世界上第一个工业化国家，在大多数指标中仍然名列前二或前三。它拥有世界上最大的帝国，拥有4亿人口，占据全球四分之一的土地。它拥有迄今为止世界上最强大的海军，但关键是只有一支非常、非常小的军队。因此，尽管英国军队在过去的几十年里打过仗，但他们通常是对付祖鲁人、布尔人、阿富汗人、苏丹人等等。但由于与布尔人的战争，他们确实穿上了卡其布军服，不是吗？某种意义上，其实英国人打过的战争可能比
those continental powers. They have, but they've been little wars. They've been police actions. They've involved quite small numbers of people. Custer-esque operations. Exactly, Custer-esque. Now, Britain historically had had alliances. It's not quite right to say that Britain had always stood alone.
那些欧洲大陆强国还要多。他们确实打过，但那都是小规模战争。它们是警察行动。它们只涉及相当少的人数。卡斯特式的行动。没错，卡斯特式的。现在，英国历史上曾有过同盟。说英国总是孤立无援是不大准确的。
So, you know, the Napoleonic Wars, for example, Britain had been part of lots of different coalitions. And the way that British foreign policy had usually worked was that Britain relied on its navy, it had a small army, and it basically paid other people to do the fighting. So obviously the Prussians, for example, against Napoleon. And in the Seven Years' War as well. Exactly, in the Seven Years' War. But recently, Britain has had this policy of so-called splendid isolation.
所以，比如说拿破仑战争，英国曾是许多不同同盟的一部分。而英国外交政策通常的运作方式是，英国依靠其海军，它拥有一支小规模军队，基本上是花钱雇别人去打仗。所以很明显，比如普鲁士人对抗拿破仑。还有七年战争中也是。没错，在七年战争中。但最近，英国奉行这种所谓的“光荣孤立”政策。
So Lord Salisbury, who was Prime Minister at the turn of the 20th century, had said our policy was to float lazily downstream, putting out the occasional diplomatic boat hook. Great days, Dominic. Great days. Yeah, I like this sort of wind in the willows analogy. Yeah, with a picnic hamper. Exactly. But actually, round about the time of the Boer War, which didn't go terribly well for Britain at first, there was a sort of sense, well, actually, we've missed a trick here. We're fighting fires on lots of different fronts in the colonies, and we don't really have any friends.
因此，在20世纪之交担任首相的索尔兹伯里勋爵曾说过，我们的政策是懒洋洋地顺流而下，偶尔伸出一根外交的船钩。好日子，多米尼克。好日子。是的，我喜欢这种《柳林风声》的比喻。是的，带着野餐篮。没错。但事实上，大约在布尔战争前后，这场战争一开始对英国来说并不算太顺利，有一种感觉，好吧，其实我们在里头漏算了一招。我们在殖民地的许多不同战线上疲于奔命，而且我们真的没有什么朋友。
So Joseph Chamberlain, colonial secretary, had said, we have no allies, we have no friends, we stand alone. And he had wanted an alliance with Germany, and had got no joy out of it. So in the end, Britain had signed or agreed the Entente Cordiale with France in 1904. Which is a seismic change, isn't it? A massive change. Because we've said how previously, basically all these wars are being fought against France
所以殖民地大臣约瑟夫·张伯伦曾说过，我们没有盟友，我们没有朋友，我们孤立无援。他曾想要与德国结盟，却没有得到任何好结果。所以最终，英国在1904年与法国签署或达成了《挚诚协定》。这是一个翻天覆地的变化，不是吗？巨大的变化。因为我们之前说过，基本上所有这些战争都是针对法国打的
and Britain's continental ally is Prussia, a German state. Yeah. And now it's kind of veering around the other way. And now Britain has switched horses. But Dominic, is that because Britain has a sense that you should always ally with a lesser power against the most threatening power on the continent? And is there a sense now that Germany has become what France used to be? And so the roles have switched? I think that's a huge part of it, that Britain has always wanted to ensure that the continent
而英国在欧洲大陆的盟友是普鲁士，一个德国国家。是的。而现在它正在朝着另一个方向转变。现在英国换了马。但多米尼克，这是不是因为英国有一种感觉，即你总是应该与一个较弱的权势结盟，去对抗欧洲大陆上最具威胁的权势？现在是不是有一种感觉，德国已经变成了过去法国的角色？所以角色调换了？我认为这是其中很大一部分原因，英国一直希望确保欧洲大陆
is not dominated by a single power. So it makes sense that you ally with somebody a tier down, as it were, against the kind of the top power on the continent. But also, as with the subsequent convention that we signed with Russia in 1907, there is an argument among a lot of historians that actually what these are, are Britain looking at the map and looking at where the big flashpoints are and saying, we will ally with those countries with whom we are most likely to have friction, to basically dampen down the friction on our colonial frontiers. So with France, for example, there had been a war scare as recently as 1898 in the Sudan, the so-called Fashoda, or Fashoda, I don't know how you pronounce it actually, because I've never been and never spoken to any sudanese person about this incident so this is a mystery to me anyway well if we have any sudanese listeners let us know yeah so kitchener
不被单一势力所主宰。因此，与低一个级别的国家结盟，去对抗大陆上的顶级势力，这是合乎逻辑的。但同时，正如我们在1907年与俄国签署的后续公约一样，许多历史学家认为，实际上这些是英国在查看地图，寻找最大的冲突爆发点，并表示：我们将与那些最有可能与我们产生摩擦的国家结盟，以便基本上平息我们殖民地边境上的摩擦。比如与法国，早在1898年在苏丹就曾发生过一次战争恐慌，所谓的法绍达（Fashoda），或者法绍达，其实我不知道该怎么发音，因为我从来没去过，也从来没有和任何苏丹人谈起过这件事，所以这对我来说是个谜。总之，如果有任何苏丹听众，请让我们知道。是的，所以基臣那
and a french guy had basically marched from different directions arrived at this place the french had been completely outnumbered and had been slightly humiliated it was a big deal and they want to avoid that happening again and of course they really want to avoid it with Russia. So for example, in his book, The Sleepwalkers, great historian, Christopher Clark, Regis professor at Cambridge, he says, in a way you could argue it's a kind of appeasement that Russia is a big threat to our empire in Asia. We've had a great game with Russia. With India, isn't it? The jewel in the crown. Yeah. And the fear that Russian forces
和一个法国人基本上从不同的方向出发，到达了这个地方，法国人完全寡不敌争，而且有点受辱，这是一件大事，他们希望避免这种情况再次发生。当然，他们真的希望避免与俄国发生这种情况。例如，在其著作《梦游者》中，剑桥大学雷吉斯教授、伟大的历史学家克里斯托弗·克拉克说，在某种程度上你可以认为这是一种绥靖政策，因为俄国对我们在亚洲的帝国构成了巨大威胁。我们和俄国进行了一场大博弈。为了印度，对吧？皇冠上的明珠。是的。人们担心俄国军队
will push down into India. Right. That this is a great way of managing that. That if you actually sign an alliance with them, then, you know, that's fine. India is protected. Same with France in Africa or Southeast Asia or wherever it might be. And actually the foreign office bigwigs say this quite explicitly. There's a guy called Charles Harding in 1909, and he writes a memo and he says, well, why are we allied with Russia, which doesn't seem a natural fit for us at all, rather than, say, Germany, which a lot of people think would be a natural fit. Great ties of kind of the royal family's culture. At this point, the late 19th, 30th, 20th century, there's all this stuff about kind of racial kindred, kith and kin, all of that kind of stuff. So Saxons.
会南下压入印度。对。这是一种管理这种局面的绝佳方式。如果你真的与他们签署同盟，那么，你知道，那就没问题了。印度就受到保护了。非洲或东南亚或任何地方的法国也是如此。实际上，外交部的大佬们非常明确地表达了这一点。1909年有个叫查尔斯·哈丁的人，他写了一份备忘录说，好吧，为什么我们与俄国结盟——这在我们看来似乎一点也不自然——而不是与德国结盟呢？很多人认为德国才是自然的选择。有着皇室文化的伟大纽带。此时，在19世纪末、30世纪、20世纪，到处都是关于某种血缘、同胞、亲戚之类的东西，所有这些东西。所以是撒克逊人。
Saxons, exactly. And so Charles Harding says, it's because we don't really have any issues with Germany. The only one is the naval race, which we are winning. But he says our whole future in Asia is bound up with maintaining the best and most friendly relations with Russia. And the bigger and more powerful that Russia becomes, the more it industrializes, the more railways they build, all of that stuff, the more that people in the Foreign Office say, look, we absolutely have to keep the Russians on side. So Harding's successor, who's a guy called Sir Arthur Nicholson, he's very explicit about this. He says it is much more disadvantageous to us to have an unfriendly France and Russia than to have an unfriendly Germany.
撒克逊人，完全正确。因此查尔斯·哈丁说，这是因为我们与德国真的没有什么问题。唯一的问题是海军竞赛，而我们正在赢得这场竞赛。但他说，我们在亚洲的全部未来，都与同俄国保持最好、最友好的关系息息相关。俄国变得越庞大、越强大，它工业化得越多，他们修建的铁路越多，所有这些事情，外交部的人就越是说，看，我们绝对必须把俄国拉拢在自己这一边。因此，哈丁的继任者——一个叫亚瑟·尼科尔森爵士的人，他对此非常明确。他说，拥有一个不友好的法俄两国，对我们的不利程度，远大于拥有一个不友好的德国。
And so what that implies is that the empire is actually a bit of a millstone, that it is kind of pulling British foreign policy off courses that it would otherwise be taking. Yeah. Isn't that interesting? That the sole priority really is the protection of the empire. And because of the protection of the empire, we have had to ally with people that maybe is a tiny bit distasteful. I mean, certainly with Russia. So remember, this is a liberal government.
因此，这意味着帝国实际上有点像一个磨盘，它把英国的外交政策从原本会采取的航向上拉偏了。是的。这难道不有趣吗？唯一的首要任务实际上是保护帝国。正因为要保护帝国，我们不得不与那些可能有点令人倒胃口的人结盟。我是说，当然是与俄国结盟。所以记住，这是一个自由党政府。
So there are lots of kind of do-gooders in this government. And they look at Russia and they say, really? Russia? You know, the most autocratic country in Europe? Yeah. Against Germany? Germany, science, you know, high culture. Social democracy.
因此，这个政府里有很多这类好德行的人。他们看着俄国说，真的吗？俄国？你知道的，欧洲最专制的国家？是的。对抗德国？德国，科学，你知道的，高级文化。社会民主主义。
Big trade unions, all that. Really? We're going with the Russians? And the foreign office people say, hey, we've got to be realistic. It's all about protecting the empire. This is what makes most sense. So that doesn't necessarily translate
庞大的工会，所有这些。真的吗？我们要跟俄国人混？外交部的人说，嘿，我们必须现实一点。这一切都是为了保护帝国。这才是最合乎逻辑的。所以这并不一定转化为
into anti-German feeling, does it? And yet, as we've often talked on this podcast, there is a kind of anti-German mood abroad in England at that time. There are all those kind of books about the Battle of the Dorking Gap and when William came. It's kind of scare stories about a German conquest of Britain. Yes, uniquely after the Franco-Prussian War. So those hadn't existed really before. But after Germany is created in 1870, you're absolutely right, Tom, you get this
反德情绪，对吧？然而，正如我们经常在这个播客中谈到的那样，当时英国国内确实弥漫着一种反德情绪。到处都是关于《道金斯峡谷战役》和《威廉来袭》之类的小说。这是一种关于德国征服英国的恐慌故事。是的，特别是在普法战争之后。所以在以前确实不存在这些。但在1870年德国建立之后，汤姆，你说的完全对，你会产生这种
sort of growing anxiety about Germany. And it really, really starts to kick in, I think, round about the very late end of the 1890s, the Boer War. You know, we're fighting Boers who are not so dissimilar from Germans. Well, the Germans, I mean, the Kaiser famously sends supportive telegrams, doesn't he? He does, the Kaiser. And in fact, lots of Germans, and frankly, lots of other people around the world, say that plucky Boer underdogs and these bullying shopkeeper you know they're british with the butcher's apron exactly so there's a lot of stuff about that there are all those as you said i mean i love all that invasion scare stuff it'd be brilliant subjects actually for a podcast really whipped up by the north cliff newspapers so my old stamping grounds the daily mail very prominent in that because they basically they would publish scare stories
对德国日益增长的焦虑。我认为，这种焦虑在19世纪末期、布尔战争前后真正开始爆发。你知道的，我们在和布尔人作战，他们和德国人并没有太大区别。嗯，德国人，我是说，威廉皇帝曾发过著名的支持电报，不是吗？是的，皇帝发过。事实上，许多德国人，坦率地说，世界上许多其他人也说，勇敢的布尔人是受欺负的弱者，而这些飞扬跋扈的店老板，你知道的，他们是带着屠夫围裙的英国人，完全正确。所以有很多关于这方面的言论，正如你所说，我的意思是，所有那些入侵恐慌的故事我都喜欢——其实这会是播客的绝佳题材——由北克利夫报系大肆炒作，所以我的老根据地《每日邮报》在这方面非常显眼，因为他们基本上会发表恐慌故事
in places where their circulation was low. Yeah. Well, what they did was the key battles took place in places where they had lots of readers, because to terrify Watford, sacked by the Prussians or whatever. And then the other thing is the naval race. Once the German Empire was established
在他们发行量很低的地方。是的。嗯，他们所做的是，关键战役发生在他们拥有大量读者的地方，因为要恐吓沃特福德，让它被普鲁士人洗劫或诸如此类。然后另一件事是海军竞赛。一旦德意志帝国建立
and then once it sort of got going, they decided they'd like a fleet. A fleet is seen in the 1890s as really the supreme badge. It's like having nuclear weapons or something. This is your ticket to the top table. The British were very offended by this. They start building dreadnoughts, and this creates a lot of antagonism. But actually, Britain wins that naval race hands down.
并且一旦它开始运转，他们决定他们想要一支舰队。在19世纪90年代，舰队被视为真正的至高无上的象征。这就像拥有核武器之类的东西。这是你进入顶级牌桌的门票。英国人对此感到非常被冒犯。他们开始建造无畏舰，这产生了大量的对立情绪。但实际上，英国轻而易举地赢得了那场海军竞赛。
By 1913, the Germans have unilaterally declared, it's over, we can't compete, we're not going to carry on building dreadnoughts at the same rate. Fine, have your naval advantage. So that actually means that as you get to 1914, the temperature is a little bit lower than it had been. Yeah. So we've already mentioned it, that trip to Berlin by Haldane, Richard Haldane. Yeah, the war minister. The war minister to try and kind of form a German equivalent of the Entente Cordiale. I mean, it fails, but presumably it's a sign that actually relations between them are thawing. Yes, I think so. I mean, because on the kind of personal level, there are lots of people in the British upper
到1913年，德国人单方面宣布，结束了，我们竞争不过了，我们不会以同样的速度继续建造无畏舰了。好吧，那就让你们保持海军优势吧。所以这实际上意味着，当你进入1914年时，气氛比以前稍微缓和了一些。是的。所以我们已经提到过了，理查德·霍尔丹对柏林的访问。是的，战争大臣。战争大臣试图建立一个德国版的《挚诚协定》。我的意思是，它失败了，但大概这表明他们之间的关系实际上正在融冰。是的，我想是的。因为在某种个人层面上，英国上层阶级的许多人
classes who are very, very keen on Germany to a degree that is, you know, is not comparable today. No. People have been massively influenced by German culture for an entire century, going back to the time of Coleridge, George Eliot, all those kind of intellectuals, hugely influenced by Germany in a way that would be inconceivable today. I mean, I think you could reasonably argue that if there was a point in recent, in modern British history, when people were most keen on Germany and German culture,
非常、非常热衷于德国，这种程度在今天是无可比拟的。没有。整整一个世纪以来，人们一直深受德国文化的影响，追溯到柯勒律治、乔治·艾略特等知识分子的时代，他们受德国的影响之深，在今天是不可想象的。我的意思是，我认为你可以合乎逻辑地认为，如果说近代英国历史上有一个时期，人们对德国和德国文化最热衷的话，
it was actually in the 1900s and 1910s. Yeah, it's so ironic, isn't it? And it went both ways. So the man who had masterminded the naval race for the Germans, Grand Admiral Tirpitz, he had an English governess for his daughters, and then he sent his daughters to Cheltenham Aders College because he wanted them to have an English education. That's amazing. So even in that cabinet, in that meeting that you described so beautifully with your Churchill voice, Sir John Simon, who's one of the Liberal cabinet ministers, he had said publicly, the fellow countrymen of Shakespeare and Milton cannot look askance on the fellow countrymen of Goethe and Schiller. And those with the tradition of Wycliffe and Wesley have no ground of quarrel with the descendants of Luther. Yeah. There's the famous German joke about Shakespeare, isn't it? That the English translation of Shakespeare isn't bad. Yeah. Well, the Germans absolutely adore and look
实际上正是在20世纪00年代和1910年代。是的，这太讽刺了，不是吗？而且是双向的。因此，为德国人策划海军竞赛的那个人，海军大将提尔皮茨，他的女儿们请了一位英国女家庭教师，后来他还把女儿们送到切尔滕纳姆女子学院，因为他希望她们接受英国教育。这太惊人了。所以即使在那个内阁中，在你用丘吉尔的嗓音优美地描述的那场会议上，西蒙爵士——自由党内阁大臣之一——曾公开表示：莎士比亚和弥尔顿的同胞，不能对歌德和席勒的同胞侧目而视。而那些拥有威克里夫和卫斯理传统的人，与路德的后代也没有任何争吵的理由。是的。关于莎士比亚，有一个著名的德国笑话，不是吗？莎士比亚的英文翻译还不错。是的。嗯，德国人绝对崇拜并仰慕英国的高级文化。这是毫无疑问的。所以你有这个。现在你确实在外交部有一些非常看低德国的人。我们在故事的稍后部分会讲到其中一位。但克里斯托弗·克拉克在《梦游者》中谈到了这一点。他说，有一连串源源不断的备忘录和会议纪要，都在争论柏林构成的威胁。他有一个很好的比喻，我认为可以进一步发展。他说，所有这些人，他们读过那些爱德华时代的的故事，里面讲的是学校里来了一个新男孩。你知道的，他可能有点粗俗。新贵。是的，新钱。他是暴发户，而且有点爱吹牛，他可能有点粗俗
up to British high culture. There's no question about that. So you have that. Now you do have people in the foreign office who are very down on Germany. And we'll get into one of them a little bit later in the story. But Christopher Clarke talks about this in The Sleepwalkers. He says there's a steady stream of memos and minutes arguing about the threat posed by Berlin. And he has a lovely analogy, which I think could be developed even further. He says all of these people, they read those kind of Edwardian stories in which there's a new boy at the school. You know, he's maybe a bit vulgar. New money. Yeah, new money. He's coming from new money, and he's a bit of a braggart, and he's maybe a bit vulgar new money yeah new money he's coming from new money and he's a
暴发户，是的，暴发户。他是暴发户，而且有点爱吹牛，是个爱吹牛皮的人，老男孩们会惩罚他、驯服他。是的，他不熟悉学校的传统规则。我的意思是，他说，外交部的官僚们就是这样谈论德国的。当然，顺便说一句，这也是威廉皇帝的亲戚们谈论他的方式。皇帝无疑有一种感觉，觉得自己受到了那样的对待。是的，绝对的。那个在宿舍里没有受到热烈欢迎的新男孩。当然，让这一切具有额外火药味的是，德国发展得太好了。
bit of a braggart and he's a blusterer and the older boys sort of punish him and tame him yeah he's not familiar with the traditional rules of the school i mean he says this is how foreign office mandarins talked about germany and of course this by the way is how kaiser wilhelm's relatives talk about him the kaiser undoubtedly has a feeling that he's being treated a bit like that. Yeah, absolutely. The new boy who's not being made to feel welcome in the dorm. And of course, what gives that an extra charge is that Germany's doing so well.
因此，到第一次世界大战爆发时，德国在工业生产上已经超越了英国。它在世界贸易份额上紧随英国之后。人们注意到了这些数字。你知道的，他们对此有真实的感受。20世纪初的人们会拿印有“德国制造”的商品开玩笑。他们觉得这就像美国人在20世纪80年代和90年代看到“日本制造”或类似东西时一样令人不安。
So that Germany, by the outbreak of the First World War, has overtaken Britain in industrial production. It is right behind Britain in its share of world trade. People are aware of these figures. You know, they have a real sense of it. People make jokes in the early 20th century about products that are stamped, made in Germany. And they find that as unsettling as Americans did in the 1980s and 1990s when it was made in Japan or something.
是的。所以这可以说是美国人所说的“修昔底德陷阱”。是的，修昔底德陷阱，完全正确。崛起中的大国，按定义就一定会发起挑战。但你觉得这正确吗？你觉得，例如，英国把德国视为敌人而不是潜在盟友，是不可避免的吗？不，我认为这不是不可避免的。因为你这话的含义是说，情况完全不是这样？我认为这绝非不可避免。我们已经提到了两位不同且非常、非常具有影响力的英国政治家，约瑟夫·张伯伦和理查德·霍尔丹，他们在当时都是巨头，虽然今天可能算不上家喻户晓，但在
Yeah. So kind of what the Americans would call the Thucydides trap. Yes. The Thucydides trap, exactly. The rising power must, by definition, challenge. But do you think that's right? Do you think that it's inevitable that, for instance, Britain would see Germany as an enemy rather than as a potential ally? No, I don't think it's inevitable. Because the implication of what you're saying is that that's not the case at all? I don't think it is inevitable. We've already mentioned two different, very, very influential British politicians, Joseph Chamberlain and Richard Haldane, huge figures in their day, not maybe household names today, but huge figures in
1890年代和1900年代却是巨头，他们真的、真的很想与德国结盟。我认为普遍的感觉，当然到1914年时是：是的，我们有过争吵、争论和摩擦，但实际上现在情况好多了。因此，负责外交部的最高文官亚瑟·尼科尔森说，德国人一直在做出巨大努力，以期同我们保持尽可能最好的关系。在某种程度上，他们成功了。财政大臣大卫·劳埃德·乔治在1914年元旦接受《每日新闻》采访时说。他说，我们与德国的关系现在比多年来的任何时候都要友好得多。现在，会有些人相信你所说的那种他陷入困境的观点。外交部的一些人会说，
the 1890s, 1900s, who really, really wanted an alliance with Germany. And I think the general sense, certainly by 1914, is, yeah, we've had spats and arguments and things, but actually things are now getting much better. So Arthur Nicholson, who's running the Foreign Office, the top civil servant, says the Germans have been making great efforts to be on the best possible terms with us. And to some extent, they've succeeded. David Lloyd George, the Chancellor, gave an interview on New Year's Day in 1914 to the Daily News. And he said, our relations with Germany are infinitely more friendly now than they have been for years. Now, there'll be some people who believed that point that you make that he's trapped. Some people in the foreign office who would say,
现实地讲，德国将会向我们发起挑战，我们应该为此整装待发。对。这就像德国对待俄国的态度一样。是的。宁可早点，总比晚了好。但在英国，这种情绪要轻得多，也没有那么偏执。嗯，也是因为1914年的英国——我的意思是，我们知道这一点，因为我们做过关于复活节起义的系列节目——1914年的英国相当内向，因为它饱受各种危机的折磨，其中关于地方自治的爱尔兰辩论是
realistically, Germany is going to challenge us and we should gird our loins for that. Right. Which is exactly like the German attitude to Russia. Yeah. Sooner, better, rather than later. But it is much less charged in Britain and much less paranoid. Well, also because Britain in 1914, I mean, we know this because we did a series on the Easter Rising, that Britain in 1914 is pretty inward looking because it's wracked by all kinds of crises of which the Irish debate over home rule is the
最主要的一个。但你还有女权运动者，对吧？你还有各种罢工。所以我们倾向于认为的那种黄金夏日银行假期突然变成泥泞和阴雨的印象并不完全真实。到处都是危机。我总是记得阿斯奎斯说过的那个不可思议的评论，大意是说，好吧，至少这场战争会让我们转移注意力，不再去想爱尔兰潜在内战的恐怖。完全正确。是的，就在萨拉热窝斐迪南大公和索菲遇刺的第二天，英国陆军的亨利·威尔逊爵士对阿斯奎斯说，他说，我们将不得不把整支军队派往爱尔兰
major one. But you've got the suffragettes, haven't you? You've got kind of strikes. So the sense we tend to have of it being a kind of golden summer bank holiday suddenly that turns to mud and rain isn't entirely true. There are crises everywhere. And I always remember that incredible comment that Asquith makes to the effect that he says, well, at least the war will distract us from the horrors of potential civil war in Ireland. Exactly. Yeah, the very day after Franz Ferdinand and Sophie were assassinated in Sarajevo, Sir Henry Wilson from the British Army told Asquith, he said, we're going to have to send the entire army to Ireland
来处理地方自治带来的后果。因此，此时英国人根本没有把目光投向巴尔干半岛。当然，萨拉热窝刺杀事件在英国得到了广泛报道。《泰晤士报》第二天刊登了关于刺杀事件的七篇不同报道。而且语气是同情的。完全是同情。谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀、谋杀戴着一顶渔夫帽，上面停着一只知更鸟。是的。还有一张，他坐在长椅上，周围都是鸭子。
to deal with the consequences of home rule. So the British do not have their eyes on the Balkans at all at this point. Of course, the Sarajevo assassinations were extensively reported in Britain. The Times ran seven different stories on the assassinations the next day. And the tone is sympathetic. Totally sympathetic. murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder,
来处理地方自治带来的后果。所以此时英国人根本没把目光投向巴尔干半岛。当然，萨拉热窝暗杀事件在英国得到了广泛报道。《泰晤士报》在第二天就连篇累牍地刊登了七篇关于刺杀事件的报道。其基调是充满同情的。完全充满同情。谋杀，谋杀，谋杀...
murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, murder, year before, hadn't they? And everyone said they were such tremendous people, had actually liked them. So Buckingham Palace is in mourning. There's a big service of remembrance at Westminster Cathedral, the Catholic Cathedral. And quite a lot of the cabinet went to that service to express their condolences. So there's a natural sympathy. And then there's a sense, well, it's actually not
谋杀，谋杀，谋杀，谋杀……就在前一年，不是吗？大家还说他们是了不起的人，其实都很喜欢他们。所以白金汉宫正在服丧。威斯敏斯特大教堂（这座天主教主教座堂）举行了一场盛大的追悼仪式。内阁中相当多的人都出席了该仪式以表达哀悼。因此，这种同情是自然而然的。而且人们觉得，其实这
that big a deal, you know, in the grand scheme of things. So there's a very famous... The Guardian kicks in with very prescient editorial. Yeah. The murders will have no immediate or salient effect on the politics of Europe. Not the last time The Guardian would comically misjudge world affairs, I think it's fair to say, Tom. I don't know. And in fact, in the Foreign Office,
也没那么大不了，你知道的，从宏观格局来看。所以有一篇非常著名的社论……《卫报》发表了一篇极具先见之明的社论。是的。谋杀案不会对欧洲政治产生任何直接或显著的影响。《卫报》并非最后一次滑稽地误判世界事务，我认为这样说很公允，汤姆。我不知道。事实上，在外交部，
the general sense is this will blow over. You know, this will not be a massive deal. Now, the one person who is worried straight away, you've already described him and said he is a great hero of yours, is the foreign secretary, the man who basically runs foreign policy as a private fiefdom and has done for a decade. And that is Sir Edward Grey. So, Tom, you love Sir Edward Grey. And what is it about him that appeals to you? He is the embodiment of a certain languid superiority that I would dearly like to possess.
普遍的看法是这件事会平息的。你知道的，这不会是什么大不了的事。现在，唯一一个立刻感到担忧的人——你已经描述过他，并说他是你心目中的大英雄——就是外交大臣，这个把外交政策当作私人领地经营了十年之久的人。那就是爱德华·格雷爵士。所以，汤姆，你深爱着爱德华·格雷爵士。他身上有什么特质吸引了你？他是某种慵懒优越感的化身，而这种优越感是我非常渴望拥有的。
That you associate with yourself. No, I don't, but I aspire to it. So Edward Gray remains to this day an absolutely fated fly fisherman. His book on fly fishing is very, very highly regarded. And you'll know that I'm in the process of trying to take it up. And I'd like to give a big shout out to Jeff, who I know is a regular listener, who's doing his best to teach me so thank you jeff for all your struggles and basically when i stand there trying to cast a fly yeah if i think that it's me who's doing it it all goes wrong i get the hook in my finger or you know the line gets tangled in a tree or i spear a duck or something but if i imagine myself to be sir edward gray yeah in fact fact, I have a Sir Edward Grey hat. Oh. Which I wear.
你把它和你自己联系在一起。不，我没有，但我很向往。因此，爱德华·格雷至今仍然是一位狂热的飞蝇钓爱好者。他关于飞蝇钓的书备受推崇。你知道我正在尝试开始这项运动。我要向杰夫致以诚挚的谢意，我知道他是我们的忠实听众，他一直在尽最大努力教我，所以谢谢杰夫，感谢你为我付出的所有挣扎。基本上，当我站在那里试图抛投飞线时，是的，如果我认为是我自己在做这一切，事情就会一团糟，钩子会扎进我的手指，或者线会被树枝缠住，或者我会一枪扎到鸭子什么的。但如果我把自己想象成爱德华·格雷爵士，是的，事实上，我有一顶爱德华·格雷爵士的帽子。哦。我经常戴着它。
You're going to wear it now? Well, yeah. So people who are watching this on YouTube, I'm now going to put it on. And it's absolutely brilliant. Oh, it's a wonderful hat. Yeah. I got it from Sir Edward Grey's outfitter. So it's exactly the same one.
你现在就要戴上它吗？嗯，是的。所以正在YouTube上观看这个节目的人，我现在要把它戴上了。这真的太棒了。哦，这是一顶非常棒的帽子。是的。我是从爱德华·格雷爵士的服装供应商那里买的。所以一模一样。
And I imagine myself as Sir Edward Grey in the summer of 1914 casting. And then I can do it perfectly. Wow. So I think that's the measure of the man. Lesson for aspiring fishermen there. So Sir Edward Grey came from a Whig family. I mean, you say that. I mean, he doesn't just come from a Whig family.
我把自己想象成1914年夏天正在抛竿的爱德华·格雷爵士。然后我就能做得完美无缺。哇。所以我觉得这正是这个男人的风范所在。给有志于成为渔夫的人的一些教训。因此，爱德华·格雷出身于辉格党家庭。我的意思是，你这么说。我的意思是，他不仅仅是出身于辉格党家庭。
It's a Whig dynasty, isn't it? Yeah, a Whig dynasty. He's the great-grandnephew of the Earl Grey who introduces the Great Reform Act in 1832, but much more significantly, and the reason why he's remembered gives his name to the eponymous tea. Is that named after the Earl Grey? Yeah.
这是一个辉格党王朝，对吧？是的，一个辉格党王朝。他是格雷伯爵的曾孙外甥，后者于1832年推出了《伟大改革法案》，但更重要的是，他之所以被人们铭记，并因此而得名，是因为一种同名茶。那是因格雷伯爵而得名的吗？是的。
Oh, I didn't know that. I'm not a massive fan of, I don't like a scented tea. But it's very liberal, isn't it? Yeah, it's too liberal. So Edward Grey, you know, highborn, goes to Winchester College, one of the great schools that we talked about in our The Real Hogwarts podcasts. Then he went to Balliol College, Oxford, like his great friend Herbert Henry Asquith. And indeed you, Dominic. And indeed me, yes. Then he went to Balliol College Oxford, like his great friend Herbert Henry Asquith.
哦，我不知道。我不是那种茶的狂热粉丝，我不喜欢加香料的茶。但这非常自由主义，对吧？是的，太自由主义了。所以爱德华·格雷，你知道的，出身名门，就读于温彻斯特公学——我们在《真正的霍格沃茨》播客中讨论过的那所伟大的学校。然后他去了牛津大学贝利奥尔学院，就像他的好朋友赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯一样。还有你，多米尼克。确实如此，我。然后他去了牛津大学贝利奥尔学院，就像他的好朋友赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯一样。
And indeed you, Dominic. And indeed me, yes. And unlike me, he had a life of pure pleasure. I was a bookworm, Tom, I'm sorry to say. Didn't you play football for Balliol? I did. Gray played football for Balliol. Did he?
还有你，多米尼克。确实如此，我。但与我不同的是，他过着纯粹享乐的生活。我曾是个书呆子，汤姆，我很遗憾地承认。你没为贝利奥尔踢过足球吗？我踢过。格雷曾为贝利奥尔踢过足球。是吗？
Yeah. Probably at a higher level than I did, Tom. Maybe, but I mean, you know. That's yet another resonance with this podcast, right? Yeah. So he was actually sent down, which I wasn't. He was sent down for not doing any work. The College Minute book said he'd been in monistrial idleness and shown himself entirely ignorant of the work set for him in the vacation.
是的。水平可能比我高，汤姆。也许吧，但我的意思是，你知道的。这与本播客有着又一次的共鸣，对吧？是的。所以他实际上被勒令退学了，而我没有。他因不务正业而被勒令退学。学院会议记录记载他“沉溺于懒散，并对假期布置给他的工作表现得一无所知”。
So that's bad form. But that doesn't stop him becoming Liberal MP for a place very close to my heart, for Berwick, where I have my Scottish estate. Yeah. So, you know, it has excellent fishing, obviously, on the Tweed. Yes. And also a lot of squirrels. That's nice.
所以这很不地道。但这并没有阻止他成为一个对我来说意义非凡的地方的自由党下议院议员——贝里克，我在那里拥有苏格兰庄园。是的。所以，你知道的，那里显然有极好的垂钓场所，就在特威德河上。是的，还有许多松鼠。那很好。
A lot of red squirrels. So we've seen red squirrels up near our Scottish estate. This is really spiralling off now, this story of the First World War. I know, I know. But so his base is North Northumbria, a place called Faladon. Yes. And he's so devoted to squirrels that Lloyd George suggested that if the Germans invaded and were marching on the northeast, then he could be made to yield by a German captain who threatened to exterminate the squirrels around his house at Valadon.
有很多红松鼠。我们在苏格兰庄园附近看到过红松鼠。第一次世界大战的故事现在真的有点跑题了。我知道，我知道。但他的大本营在诺森伯兰郡北部一个叫法拉登的地方。是的。他对松鼠如此痴迷，以至于劳合·乔治建议说，如果德国人入侵并向东北部进军，可以让一个德国上尉威胁要灭绝法拉登他家周围的松鼠，以此来迫使他屈服。
I really like that. So he spends a lot of time in these country pursuits, I think partly because his private life is a bit of a mess. Not a mess, it's just a bit of a wasteland. So he married a young woman called dorothy from a big northumberland landowning family they went on honeymoon and dorothy said to him at the end of the honeymoon i actually find the physical side of marriage repulsive which is no one wants to hear that you don't want to hear that from your new bride so that side of the marriage was then dead and his biographer thomas otte says he took up competitive real tennis with greater energy.
我真的很喜欢这个。所以他花了很多时间在这些乡村消遣上，我想部分是因为他的私生活一团糟。不是一团糟，只是一片荒芜。他娶了一个名叫多萝西的年轻女子，她来自诺森伯兰郡的一个大土地拥有者家族。他们去度蜜月，蜜月结束时多萝西对他说：“其实我发现婚姻的生理方面让我感到厌恶。”没有人想听到这种话，你当然不想从新婚妻子那里听到这种话。因此，婚姻的那一部分就名存实亡了。他的传记作者托马斯·奥特说，他以更大的热情投入到了竞技实网球中。
Well, that's the solution. So, royal tennis is the one where you have a kind of very heavy ball, don't you? And it's kind of modelled on a medieval monastery or something. It's quite dangerous. But he's really good at it. Brilliant. I think he got a blue.
好吧，这就是解决办法。所以，皇家网球就是那种你拿着一个非常重的球的运动，对吧？它有点模仿中世纪的修道院什么的。挺危险的。但他真的很擅长。太棒了。我想他拿到了蓝带荣誉。
Yeah, I think he was exceptionally good. And he played squash and all these kinds of things. Yeah, he won all kinds of national championships. Yeah, so he's doing that and he spends all his weekends fly fishing and stuff. Yeah. He won all kinds of national championships. Yeah. So he's doing that and he spends all his weekends fly fishing and stuff. And in fact, somebody at the Foreign Office said he's never been abroad or hardly ever. Doesn't speak French, does he? Doesn't speak a word of any foreign languages.
是的，我认为他极其优秀。他还打壁球以及所有这类运动。是的，他赢得了各种全国锦标赛。是的，所以他一直在做这些，而且他所有的周末都花在飞蝇钓等等事情上。事实上，外交部有人说他从未出过国，或者几乎从未出过国。不会说法语，对吧？一个外国单词都不会说。
It would be advisable for him to spare some time from his ducks to learn French. But Gray obviously thinks that's not suitable for a Baleal man to do that kind of thing. I just love the idea of him, you know, of a weekend, Friday evening, he gets on the train, goes down and fishes. That for me, I mean, basically that's how I like to imagine the Edwardian period. And I know all about, you know, strikes and Ireland and everything, but the image of a man in tweed with a hat fly fishing on a lazy June afternoon. Having just spent the day settling the affairs of Montenegro. All that kind of thing.
建议他从他的鸭子那里分出一些时间来学习法语。但格雷显然认为，一个贝利奥尔学院的人去做那种事是不合适的。我只是喜欢想象他周末的样子，周五晚上，他坐上火车，下去钓鱼。对我来说，基本上这就是我喜欢想象的爱德华时代。我知道关于罢工、爱尔兰和所有这些事情，但一个穿着花呢衣服、戴着帽子、在一个慵懒的六月下午进行飞蝇钓的男人的形象。刚刚花了一天时间平定黑山事务。诸如此类。
Yeah. Or whatever he's been doing. But the thing is, he fishes in a very melancholy way, Tom. Dorothy died in 1906 in a riding accident. And Grey, he always reminds me of Thomas Hardy in this regard, who obviously is living at the same time. Thomas Hardy, when he lost his first wife, wrote all these sort of poems saying, you know, we didn't really get on and I feel so guilty.
是的。或者无论他在做什么。但问题是，他以一种非常忧郁的方式钓鱼，汤姆。多萝西于1906年在一次骑马事故中去世。在这方面，格雷总是让我想起托马斯·哈代，他显然也生活在同一时期。托马斯·哈代在失去第一任妻子时，写了所有这些诗，大致意思是，你知道的，我们其实相处得并不好，我感到非常内疚。
The clouds have gathered and all this kind of thing. And Grey absolutely, he is ravaged by a sort of strange guilt after her death. So he would have tea laid in her room when he was in your neck of the woods in Northumberland. And he would just sit there silently on his own, staring at the tea set. And he said to people, I wish I could be dead. I wish I could join her in death. I also like that melancholy strain. Yeah, well, that's very Edwardian. The worst state of all is to feel dead and to have to go on being alive. That is my difficulty now.
乌云密布，诸如此类。格雷绝对在她的死后被一种奇怪的罪恶感折磨得心力交瘁。因此，当他在你所在的诺森伯兰郡那一带时，他会让人在她的房间里摆好茶。他就会一个人静静地坐在那里，凝视着茶具。他对人们说：“我希望我能死。我希望能在死后陪伴她。”我也喜欢这种忧郁的情绪。是的，这非常具有爱德华时代的气息。最糟糕的状态莫过于感觉自己已经死了，却还不得不继续活着。这就是我现在的难处。
And then his brother is killed by a lion in Africa. That's very imperial. Very Edwardian. And then he starts to lose his sight. And for a man who basically spends all his time playing real tennis and bird watching. There's a wonderful photo of him wearing his fisherman's hat with a robin on top of it. Yes. Yeah. And another one, he's sitting on a bench surrounded by ducks.
然后他的兄弟在非洲被狮子杀死了。这非常具有帝国色彩。非常具有爱德华时代的气息。然后他开始失明。对于一个基本上把所有时间都花在打实网球和观鸟上的人来说。有一张他的精彩照片，他戴着渔夫帽，上面停着一只知更鸟。是的。是的，还有一张，他坐在一群鸭子环绕的长椅上。
Yeah. He's a very proficient birdwatcher. Now, all of this makes him sound, especially to our overseas-ness, as if a sort of muscular Australian listener to the rest is history. This will confirm all their stereotypes of the English, this sort of languid, useless, don't speak a word of the foreign language, just interested in birdwatching. But actually, he's a very serious politician. He is what's called a liberal imperialist. There was him, there was Haldane, and there was their friend, Asquith, who was the sort of the alpha male of the three.
是的。他是个非常熟练的观鸟者。现在，所有这些都让他听起来——特别是对我们这些海外人士而言——仿佛是个精壮的澳大利亚听众，而“历史其余部分”也是如此。这会证实他们对英国人的所有刻板印象，那种慵懒、无能、连一句外语都不会说、只对观鸟感兴趣的形象。但实际上，他是一位非常严肃的政治家。他被称为自由帝国主义者。当时有他，有霍尔丹，还有他们的朋友阿斯奎斯，他是这三人中的“阿尔法雄性”。
And they're liberals, so they believe in being kind to people and, you know, using the power of the three. And they're liberals, so they believe in being kind to people and using the power of the state. But they're also, they believe in smiting the burrs and carrying a big stick abroad and all that sort of thing. Faintly Blairite. Yeah, a little bit, a little bit. I can absolutely see that. So Gray took over the foreign office at the end of 1905 and he was there for 11 years. It was his domain. He's in charge of Britain's foreign policy. Nobody, I think, has ever run it for as long as he did. Certainly not in modern history. Some of the liberal MPs say, I don't like the way he just does it all secretively.
他们是自由主义者，所以他们相信对人要友善，并且，你知道的，运用三人的力量。他们是自由主义者，所以他们相信对人要友善，并运用国家的力量。但他们同时也相信，要在国外狠狠打击野蛮人、手大棒，诸如此类的事情。隐隐有点布莱尔主义的味道。是的，有一点，有一点。我完全能理解。所以格雷在1905年底接管了外交部，他在那里一呆就是11年。那是他的地盘。他掌管着英国的外交政策。我想，从来没有人像他那样掌管这么久。在现代史上绝对没有。一些自由派议员说，我不喜欢他这种完全暗箱操作的方式。
And actually, it's not very liberal. So they're kind of ethical foreign policy people. And they say, why are we pally with the Tsar? Why are we pally with Europe's most autocratic monarchy, with people being dragged off to prison in Siberia and stuff? And as you've said, it's realpolitik. Yeah, exactly. It's to protect the empire.
而且实际上，这并不是很自由。所以他们算是那种讲究道德外交的人。他们说，为什么我们要和沙皇称兄道弟？为什么我们要和欧洲最专制的君主国称兄道弟，看着人们被拖进西伯利亚的监狱等等？正如你所说，这是现实政治。是的，完全正确。这是为了保护帝国。
And they don't like that. Now, the other thing is nobody really knows what Gray has agreed with some of these foreign countries. So the classic example of that is France. We have had the Entente Cordiale since 1904, something that people are still quite sentimental about, aren't they? Whenever the British prime minister goes to visit Macron, they will make reference to the entendre cordial how brilliant it is but actually when you dig it out and you look at what it was actually all about
而他们不喜欢这样。现在，另一件事是，没有人真正知道格雷同其中一些外国达成过什么协议。最典型的例子就是法国。自1904年以来，我们一直维持着“挚诚协定”，人们对这件事至今仍抱有相当深厚的感情，不是吗？每当英国首相去访问马克龙时，他们都会提到“挚诚协定”，说它有多么了不起，但实际上，当你深究它、看看它到底是怎么回事时……
fishing rights in newfoundland and about edward the seventh going to paris and hanging out with courtesans there's that but actually the text of the stuff of course edward the seventh is going around and like smiling at his old mistresses and stuff and waving to the crowds in Paris. But the details of it, they're all about the ownership of towns in Senegal. So there is no public, written, stated agreement between France and Britain about what they would do in the event of, say, a German attack on France or indeed a German attack on Britain? No. And here is the crucial thing, right?
纽芬兰的捕鱼权，以及爱德华七世去巴黎并在那里与交际花厮混。是有这么回事，但实际上那些文件的内容……当然，爱德华七世是在四处走动，向他的前情人们微笑什么的，向巴黎的人群挥手。但其中的细节，全都是关于塞内加尔城镇所有权的。所以，法国和英国之间并没有什么公开的、书面的、明确的协议，说明如果发生诸如德国进攻法国、或者确实是德国进攻英国之类的事，他们会怎么做？没有。而这才是至关重要的一点，对吧？
So in public, people are always asking Gray this. You know, are we in an alliance with France and Russia that will require us to fight on their side if there was ever a continental war? And he says, absolutely not. No, nothing. We can do whatever we like. We don't have to get involved.
所以在公开场合，人们总是这样质问格雷。你知道的，我们是否与法俄结成了同盟，如果未来爆发欧洲大陆战争，这将迫使我们站在他们一边作战？而他的回答是，绝对没有。不，什么都没有。我们可以做任何我们喜欢做的事。我们不必卷入其中。
But in private, when the French ask him, he says to them, we'll always stand with you, you know. Now, there's a fatal ambiguity there, because in 1914, the top Mandarin, Sir Arthur Nicholson, said to him, you have promised their ambassador, Monsieur Combeau, that if Germany is ever the aggressor, you will stand by France. And Gray gives the ultimate Edwardian British response. He says, yes, but he has nothing in writing. I imagine Roger Moore would give that line very nicely.
但在私底下，当法国人问他时，他对他们说，我们永远会和你们站在一起，你知道的。现在，这里存在着一种致命的模棱两可，因为在1914年，最高文官阿瑟·尼科森爵士对他说，你曾向他们的特使孔博先生承诺，如果德国成为侵略者，你将坚定站在法国一边。而格雷给出了最典型的爱德华时期英国人的回应。他说，是的，但他没有什么书面凭据。我想罗杰·摩尔能把这句台词演得非常精彩。
Arching his eyebrow. Which is the perfidious Albion. So there is a real uncertainty about what Britain will do. Nobody outside Grey's office can be sure. In fact, I'm not even sure that he really knows himself what he would do if it came to the crunch. And what Britain will do. I guess we'll find out after the break.
挑起他的眉毛。这就是“背信弃义的阿尔比恩”。因此，英国究竟会怎么做，存在着真正的不确定性。除了格雷的办公室之外，没有人能确定。事实上，我甚至不确定他自己是否真的知道，如果到了紧要关头他会怎么做。以及英国会怎么做。我想我们会在中场休息后找到答案。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello welcome back to The Rest Is History and in this part we're looking at basically how Sir Edward Grey and the British government respond to the assassination in Sarajevo and the gathering war clouds of the July crisis. But it's also an episode that will feature two absolutely top ambassadors, isn't it, Dominic? Two of my favorite ambassadors in the whole of history. Wow.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》，在这一部分中，我们将探讨爱德华·格雷爵士和英国政府基本上是如何应对萨拉热窝刺杀事件以及七月危机中聚拢的战争阴云的。但这也是一集将出现两位绝对顶级大使的节目，对吧，多米尼克？这两位是我在整个历史中最喜欢的大使。哇。
And the first of these is the German ambassador, Karl Max, Prince Lichnowsky, who is genuinely, I think, a very admirable man. Yeah. Wonderful guy. Great wife. Yeah. He's Silesian. He's from Silesia.
其中第一位是德国大使卡尔·马克思，利希诺夫斯基亲王，我认为他真是一个非常令人钦佩的人。是的。绝佳的家伙。好妻子。是的。他是西里西亚人。他来自西里西亚。
His wife, Mectilda, is from Bohemia. And she's very, very glamorous. And their house, which is on Colton House Terrace, becomes a kind of great center for all kinds of British luminaries go there. So Kipling goes there and Shaw and members of the Bloomsbury Group. Yeah. And he has excellent coats. He's great.
他的妻子梅克蒂尔达来自波希米亚。她非常有魅力。他们在卡尔顿府邸露台的宅邸，成为了各种英国名流汇聚的中心。基普林去过那里，萧伯纳和布卢姆斯伯里派的成员也去过。是的。而且他有很多极好的大衣。他很棒。
I love him. Absolutely love him. He's very famous for his parties, isn't he? Yeah. So he's one of the richest men in Germany. He's a very suave aristocrat. He loves Britain. Everybody in high society in London says,
我爱他。绝对爱他。他以办派对而闻名，不是吗？是的。所以他是德国最富有的人之一。他是一位温文尔雅的贵族。他热爱英国。伦敦上流社会的每个人都说：
oh, he's a jolly good fellow. Prince Leklowski, oh, they're wonderful people. Now, actually, the problem that I think he has, and that actually Britain has, and Germany has in this crisis, is he loves Britain rather too much. And he hates conflict. He's actually quite a sort of nervous person behind the sort of debonair urbanity. So he loves Britain and he hates conflict. Again, he's like me. Right. Very good. All these people seem to turn out to be like you, Tom.
哦，他真是个好人。利希诺夫斯基亲王，哦，他们是一群绝妙的人。现在，实际上，我认为他所面临的问题，以及英国和德国在这个危机中所面临的问题，是他有点太热爱英国了。而且他痛恨冲突。在那种风度翩翩的温文尔雅背后，他其实是个相当容易紧张的人。所以他热爱英国，他又痛恨冲突。又来了，他就像我。没错。很好。所有这些人最后好像都变得跟你一样，汤姆。
The Kaiser? Yeah. Yes. Sir Edward Grey? Extraordinary. It's like being in your troubled psyche, different versions of yourself. So, I mean, Thomas Otte makes this point in his book, July Crisis. Prince Lichnowsky has a habit of telling Sir Edward Grey what they both want to believe.
德皇？是的。是的。爱德华·格雷爵士？太不寻常了。这就像是在探索你那充满困惑的内心世界，全都是你自己的不同版本。所以，托马斯·奥特在他的书《七月危机》中就指出了这一点。利希诺夫斯基亲王有一种习惯，就是告诉爱德华·格雷他们俩都愿意相信的事情。
Right. As in, things will all be fine. We'll be able to sort this out. It'll all be fine. Ah, don't worry. Exactly. So on the 6th of July, Lichnowsky says to Grey, this is the first time they've discussed it. So it's now over a week since the assassination.
对。也就是，一切都会好起来的。我们能解决这个问题的。一切都会好的。啊，别担心。完全正确。所以在7月6日，利希诺夫斯基对格雷说，这是他们第一次讨论此事。所以这距离暗杀发生已经过去一个多星期了。
Lichnowsky says, the Austrians are planning something, but I do not know what it is. And Grey interestingly says, well, we have to be careful not for the conflict to spread. But he says, the Austrians are planning something, but I do not know what it is. And Gray interestingly says, well, we have to be careful not for the conflict to spread. But he says, listen, I can understand they would be planning something because it's kind of unreasonable to expect them not to react at all to the heir to their throne being murdered. And that is Gray's position for quite a long time. You know, he's not quite like the French or the Russians.
利希诺夫斯基说，奥地利人正在策划什么，但我不知道是什么。而格雷有趣地回应说，嗯，我们必须小心，不能让冲突扩大。但他说，听着，我能理解他们会策划些什么，因为期望他们对王位继承人被谋杀这件事完全毫无反应，这有点不太合理。而这在相当长的一段时间里都是格雷的立场。你知道，他不像法国人或俄国人那样。
He's not, as it were, stubbornly anti-Austrian. He wants to manage this. Let's get through this. We can sort this out. And when it becomes apparent that various great powers are starting to square off over it, he sees Britain's role as a kind of mediating one, doesn't he? Yes. So there are some historians who say, right from the beginning, he should have said, oh, well, if there is a conflict, Britain will back France and Russia. So you, Germany and Austria should stand down because you don't want to be fighting us. And they say, well, what a fool Gray was. Why didn't he do that? That would have deterred them. And the reason he doesn't do that is actually, is completely understandable. He thinks somebody piling in like a bull in the
他不像那种顽固的反奥主义者。他想要掌控这一切。让我们度过难关吧。我们能解决这个问题的。当显而易见各大国开始因此而剑拔弩张时，他将英国的角色视为某种调停者，不是吗？是的。所以有些历史学家说，从一开始他就应该表态，哦，好吧，如果有冲突，英国将支持法俄。所以你们德国和奥地利应该退让，因为你们不想与我们为敌。他们说，格雷真是个傻瓜。他为什么不这么做？那本可以威慑到他们。而他之所以不这么做，实际上是完全可以理解的。他认为有人像头蛮牛一样横冲直撞进……
china shop, kind of Kaiser style with sort of threats and menaces is the last thing you need what you need is somebody to say we will be the honest broker we will mediate you know we're not going to pick a side we won't threaten the germans we will work with them they will probably be the people we end up working with to calm all this down but i suppose the problem with that is that britain does have an entente cordiale with France. It is in a kind of alliance with Russia. Yeah. And Austria presumably would not be part of this because Austria and Serbia are the two who have to be, you know, the mediation has to operate.
瓷器店，那种带着威胁和恐吓的德皇风格，正是最不需要的东西。你需要的是有人站出来说，我们将成为诚实的中间人，我们将进行调停，你知道，我们不会选边站，我们不会威胁德国人，我们会同他们合作，他们可能最终会成为我们与之合作、平息这一切的人。但我想，这其中存在的问题是，英国确实与法国有着“挚诚协定”。它与俄罗斯处于某种联盟关系。是的。而奥地利大概不会成为其中的一部分，因为奥地利和塞尔维亚是那两个必须被……你知道，调停必须对之起作用的对象。
So that means that Germany essentially is outnumbered three to one or would feel that it's outnumbered three to one. Yes, I think that's right. I think that's absolutely right. Because Britain actually isn't an honest broker in this. I mean, it has skin in the game, really. This is the ambiguity of Gray's position, because actually Gray is also meeting other ambassadors. For example, he meets the Russian ambassador, Count von Benkendorf. Everybody has the wrong name. Lichnowsky and Benkendorf should have swapped surnames. Bizarrely, I mean, or not bizarrely, given how Edwardian
这意味着德国基本上是以一敌三，或者会觉得自己是以一敌三。是的，我认为是这样的。我认为完全是这样。因为英国在这里其实并不是一个诚实的中间人。我的意思是，它确实在这场博弈中有着自身的切身利益。这就是格雷立场的模棱两可之处，因为实际上格雷也在会见其他大使。例如，他会见了俄国大使冯·本肯多夫伯爵。每个人的名字都弄错了。利希诺夫斯基和本肯多夫应该把姓氏对调一下。奇怪的是，或者说，考虑到爱德华时期……
diplomatic politics works, Benkendorf, the Russian ambassador, and Lichnowsky, the German ambassador, are cousins. Of course they are. So he meets him and he says to him, what we should perhaps do is reassure the Germans. We don't want the Germans to be too isolated. We want to reassure them. You know, he still thinks the Russians, the French, the Germans, indeed the Austrians, they're all solid chaps.
外交政治是如何运作的，本肯多夫，这位俄国大使，和利希诺夫斯基，这位德国大使，是表兄弟。他们当然是。所以他会见了他，并对他说，我们或许应该做的是安抚德国人。我们不希望德国人被孤立得太厉害。我们希望安抚他们。你知道，他依然认为俄国人、法国人、德国人，甚至奥地利人，全都是靠谱的家伙。
They can all be brought to see sense. Of course there are differences between them. But if I show myself to be a man of good faith, they will all agree to to see sense of course there are differences between them but if i show myself to be a man of good faith they will all agree to some sort of mediation and as you said tom that's slightly missing the point that he's already promised the french that when it comes to the crunch he will be on their side so they can kind of ignore him if they want they don't have to go with his kind of mediation proposals so So right up to the point when the Austrians issue their ultimatum, he is still pretty sympathetic to Austria.
他们都能被说服认清道理。当然他们之间存在分歧。但如果我表现得像个笃守信义的人，他们都会同意去认清道理。当然他们之间存在分歧。但如果我表现得像个笃守信义的人，他们都会同意某种调停。正如你所说，汤姆，这有点忽视了重点，那就是他已经向法国人承诺过，一旦到了紧要关头，他会站在他们一边，所以如果他们愿意，他们可以某种程度上无视他，他们不必遵循他那种调停提议。所以，直到奥地利人发出最后通牒的那一刻，他对奥地利依然相当同情。
So the 22nd of July, he meets the Austrian ambassador. Like all Austrian ambassadors, he has an enormous name. Count Albert Victor Julius Josef Michael Graf von Menzdorf Puli Dichter Dietrichstein. Crazy name, crazy guy. We call him Count Menzdorf. And Menzdorf reports to Vienna. He says, Grey is not without sympathy for us. He's very cool.
所以7月22日，他会见了奥地利大使。像所有奥地利大使一样，他有一个极长的名字：阿尔伯特·维克托·尤利乌斯·约瑟夫·迈克尔·格拉夫·冯·门斯多夫-普伊-迪特里希施泰因伯爵。疯狂的名字，疯狂的家伙。我们叫他门斯多夫伯爵。门斯多夫向维也纳汇报。他说，格雷对我们并非没有同情心。他非常冷冷静。
He's very friendly. He is worried about what will happen. And actually, the ambassador says to Vienna, I am anxious that when Grey sees our ultimatum, he will be really shocked. And he is, isn't he? And he is, isn't he? And he is. So that meeting that you described in your Churchill voice, Tom, 24th of July, Gray reads that out to his cabinet colleagues and he says, this is the most formidable declaration I've ever seen addressed by one state to another.
他非常友好。他很担心将会发生的事情。实际上，这位大使对维也纳说，我担心当格雷看到我们的最后通牒时，他会被吓一大跳。而他确实如此，不是吗？而他确实如此，不是吗？而他确实如此。所以那场你用丘吉尔的嗓音描述的会议，汤姆，7月24日，格雷向他的内阁同僚宣读了这份文件，他说，这是我见过的由一个国家发给另一个国家的最为可怕的宣言。
And they all say, well, the one thing we don't want to do is to get involved in a world war. They're absolutely adamant about that. And they say to him, the thing to do is you go to the Germans and you go to the French and the three of you together should be able to persuade the Austrians and the Russians not to fall out about this. Now, of course, what that completely misses, they do not realize how committed the decision makers in Paris and Berlin already are. So it's a failure of intelligence. I think it is a little bit.
而他们都说，我们最不想做的事情就是卷入一场世界大战。他们对此态度绝对坚决。他们对他说，现在该做的是你去一趟德国，再去一趟法国，你们三方联手应该能够说服奥地利和俄罗斯不要为这件事闹翻。现在，当然，他们完全忽视的一点是，他们没有意识到巴黎和柏林的决策者们已经投入得有多深。所以这是一个情报失败。我想确实有一点。
It's amazing to me that until such a late stage, Gray, perhaps misled actually by some of those ambassadors in London who have gone a bit native, he doesn't get that actually the partners for his various mediation proposals just don't actually exist. But there is, of course, an ambassador in London who has not gone native. And that is the French ambassador, Paul Cambon, who we've already mentioned.
令我惊奇的是，直到这么晚的阶段，格雷——或许实际上是被伦敦那些有点“本土化”的大使们所误导——他依然没有搞清楚，他那些各种调停提议的伙伴实际上根本不存在。但当然，伦敦有一位并没有“本土化”的大使。那就是我们已经提到过的法国大使保罗·康邦。
Yes. Who has been in London since 1898 as ambassador. 16 years. But just as Grey does not speak a word of French, Paul Cambon does not speak a word of English.
是的。他自1898年起就一直在伦敦担任大使。16年了。但正如格雷一句法语都不会说一样，保罗·康邦一句英语都不会说。
Despite having been in the country for 16 years. And I hugely admire that. That is what I want from a French ambassador. I mean, the amazing thing, I can't remember where I've got this from. I think it's from Chris that. That is what I want from a French ambassador. I mean, the amazing thing, I can't remember where I've got this from. I think it's from Chris Clark.
尽管他已经在英国待了16年。我极其佩服这一点。这正是我对法国大使的期望。我的意思是，神奇的是，我不记得我是从哪儿看到这个的了。我想我是从克里斯那……这正是我对法国大使的期望。我的意思是，神奇的是，我不记得我是从哪儿看到这个的了。我想我是从克里斯·克拉克那儿看到的。
It is. He's very funny about Cambon. During his meetings, Cambon insisted that every single utterance be translated into French, including easily recognized words such as yes. Yeah. So when Gray said to him, yes,
确实是的。他对康邦的评价非常有趣。在会面期间，康邦坚持要把说的每一句话都翻译成法语，包括像“是”这样容易辨认的词。是的。所以当格雷对他说“是”时，
this little man at the side would say oui. And also his opposition to there being French schools in England on the grounds that anyone who goes to such schools are likely to grow up intellectually stunted. Yes. And can you think of anybody, Tom? Can you think of anybody, a Frenchman who went to a school in England and possibly,
旁边这个小个子男人就会说“oui”。还有他反对在英国设立法国学校，理由是任何去这种学校上学的人长大后智力都可能会发育受阻。是的。你能想到什么人吗，汤姆？你能想到什么人吗，一个在英国上过学的法国人，可能……
you know, there are question marks about his acumen and maybe his life choices. Theo. Poor old Theo. And also the weird thing is that Cambon's brother, Jules, is the ambassador to Germany. So again, it's all a kind of family affair, isn't it? Yeah. So they met, Grey and Cambon, after that cabinet meeting on the 24th of July. And Gray said, I've dreamed up a solution to this crisis.
你知道的，人们对他的精明以及他的人生选择存在疑问。特奥。可怜的老特奥。而且奇怪的是，康邦的弟弟儒勒是驻德国大使。所以这又是一桩家族事务，不是吗？是的。所以，7月24日內阁会议结束后，格雷和康邦会面了。格雷说，我想出了一种解决这场危机的方法。
And it's a four-power mediation. So there'll be four mediators. There'll be Britain, France, Germany, and Italy. And between us, we can sort this out. Now, there are massive problems with this idea that Gray doesn't realize. Number one is France and Germany don't even want to do it, really. They're not signed up to the idea of mediation because they are both already signed up to the idea
那就是四国调停。所以将会有四个调停国。将会有英国、法国、德国和意大利。在我们之间，我们可以解决这个问题。现在，这个想法存在着格雷没有意识到的巨大问题。第一点是法国和德国甚至根本不想这么做。他们并不赞同调停的想法，因为他们双方都已经赞同了
of calling your opponents bluff and not backing down and being firm and all that business. But also that lineup that he's described would inevitably vote 3-1 against Austria because Britain and France are kind of allies with Russia and Serbia. Germany obviously with Austria and Italy nominally with Germany and Austria but actually hates the Austrians.
虚张声势、绝不退让、立场坚定以及那一套做法。但同时，他所描述的那套阵容不可避免地会在投票中以3比1反对奥地利，因为英国和法国基本上是俄罗斯和塞尔维亚的盟友。德国显然与奥地利站在一起，意大利名义上与德奥同盟，但实际上痛恨奥地利人。
So that is a problem. Gray doesn't realize it, of course. And neither does Asquith, does he? Because on the 24th of July, the same day that Gray is talking to Campbell, Asquith is writing in his journal, we are within measurable or imaginable distance of real Armageddon. And the we there is Europe. Happily, there seems to be no reason why we, meaning Britain, should be anything more than spectators.
所以这是一个问题。格雷当然没有意识到这一点。阿斯奎斯也没有，对吧？因为在7月24日，也就是格雷与康邦谈话的同一天，阿斯奎斯在他的日记中写道：我们正处于距离真正的世界末日可测量或可想象的范围内。那里的“我们”是指欧洲。所幸的是，似乎没有任何理由让我们——意指英国——不仅仅扮演旁观者的角色。
Yes. So just on Asquith, Asquith, a great friend of the rest of history, much-loved prime ministerial figure, much maligned, I think, by some people at Goldhanger, Tom, very cruelly. So Asquith, famously the kind of incarnation of the effortless superiority of the Balliol man. We know a lot about what he's thinking during this period because he's slightly letting himself down, isn't he? He's got a bit of a crush on his daughter's best friend. So his daughter's Violet and her best friend is called Venetia Stanley. She's 26 years old.
是的。说回到阿斯奎斯，阿斯奎斯，他是《历史其余部分》的挚友，一位备受喜爱的首相人物，我认为他被戈尔德亨格的一些人恶毒地诋毁了，汤姆。所以阿斯奎斯，众所周知，他是贝利奥尔学院男子那种毫不费力的优越感的化身。我们对他在这一时期的想法了解很多，因为他有点自甘堕落了，不是吗？他有点迷恋他女儿最好的朋友。所以他女儿叫维奥莱特，她最好的朋友叫维妮西亚·斯坦利。她26岁。
Asquith is 62. 62. best friend is called Venetia Stanley. She's 26 years old. Asquith is 62. 62. So I'm not defending it, Tom. It is what it is. So he's sending her all these love letters and he will often write to her. I mean, he actually writes to her during cabinet meetings, which I think is probably not ideal. You can't imagine Theresa May doing that. No, absolutely not.
阿斯奎斯62岁。62岁。最好的朋友叫维妮西亚·斯坦利。她26岁。阿斯奎斯62岁。62岁。所以我不是在为他辩护，汤姆。事实就是如此。所以他给她写了所有这些情书，他经常给她写信。我的意思是，他甚至在内阁会议期间给她写信，我认为这大概不太理想。你无法想象特蕾莎·梅会这么做。不，绝对不会。
There is one recent prime minister I can imagine doing that but let's not bring him into it yes so um he says to venetia that evening i'm worried the russia is trying to drag us into the war and he actually then goes on to say and i think this absolutely captures the british attitude askwith says the curious thing is that on many if not most of the points austria has a good and serbia a very bad case but the Austrians are quite the stupidest people in Europe. And there is a brutality of their mode of procedure, which will make most people think it's a case of a big power wantonly bullying a little one.
我能想象最近有一位首相会这么做，但我们还是别把他牵扯进来了。是的。所以，他在那天晚上对维妮西亚说，我担心俄国人正试图把我们拖入战争。然后他实际上接着说道，我认为这绝对抓住了英国人的态度，阿斯奎斯说，奇怪的是，在许多（如果不是大多数）问题上，奥地利的立场是正当的，而塞尔维亚的立场是非常糟糕的。但奥地利人是欧洲最愚蠢的一群人。他们做事的方式带有一种野蛮性，会让大多数人觉得这是一个大国在恶意霸凌一个小国。
And another point, actually, he writes to her and he says, what the Serbs need is a damn good thrashing. So the British are not Serbophile by any means. And they're not Austrophobic. But all they want to do is they want to see Serbia get a bit of a slap on the wrist from the Austrians so the Austrians are happy, and then it all calmed down and they can go back to their fishing. And he can play bridge and think about Venetia Stanley. That's basically Asquith's dream scenario.
还有一点，实际上，他写信给她说，塞尔维亚人需要的是狠狠地挨上一顿痛揍。所以英国人绝不是亲塞尔维亚派。他们也不是反奥派。但他们只想看到塞尔维亚被奥地利人狠狠打一巴掌，好让奥地利人高兴，然后一切平息下来，他们就可以回去钓鱼了。而他就可以玩桥牌、想着维妮西亚·斯坦利。这基本上就是阿斯奎斯梦寐以求的场景。
And Grey's too, actually. I mean, Grey, unbelievably. He goes off fishing, doesn't he? He actually goes fishing the next day. Yeah, tremendous behavior. This is the day, the 25th of July, Saturday, Tom, that the ultimatum expires. And Grey, who you might expect to stay at least in London, says, no, I'm going to go fishing. And actually, he goes off to his country cottage, which is on the River Itchen. I've seen it.
格雷也是如此，事实上。我的意思是，格雷，难以置信的是。他去钓鱼了，不是吗？他第二天真的去钓鱼了。是的，太棒了。这就是那一天，7月25日，星期六，汤姆，最后通牒到期的日子。而本该至少留在伦敦的格雷却说，不，我要去钓鱼。实际上，他去了他位于伊钦河畔的乡间小屋。我见过它。
Well, this is where the most controversial person in this whole story makes his appearance, right? Because not only have you seen it, you went there with the Fox-murdering anti-Brexit lawyer, Jolyon Morm. He's a charming man. Well, I don't want to lose all our listeners, all our British listeners. I went there with Fergal Shockey,
嗯，这个故事里最具争议的人物就是在这里登场的，对吧？因为不仅你见过，你还和那个虐狐的反脱欧律师乔恩·莫姆一起去过。他是个迷人的人。好吧，我可不想失去我们所有的听众，我们所有的英国听众。我是和费尔加·肖基一起去的，
who's Undertone's lead singer, but is also now campaigning basically against poo being dumped in our beloved rivers. Yeah, sewage. Sewage is his thing. And we walked the itchen, and he brought Jolly and Morm, who was delightful. Really?
他是“地下天王”乐队的主唱，但现在基本上也在发起反对将粪便倾倒进我们深爱的河流中的运动。是的，污水。污水是他的专长。我们沿着伊钦河散步，他带来了乔恩·莫姆，人非常可爱。真的吗？
Yeah, I liked him very much. Oh, my word, Tom. But Dominic, I like everyone. You do, you do. I mean, to our overseas listeners, this is just mad babble. But British listeners can make their own minds up, as they can about other controversial characters such as the kaiser and other such people right this is all a massive
是的，我很喜欢他。我的天呐，汤姆。但多米尼克，我喜欢所有人。你确实，你确实。我的意思是，对我们的海外听众来说，这简直是胡言乱语。但英国听众可以自己做出判断，就像他们对其他颇具争议的人物（如德皇和其他这样的人）所做的那样。好吧，这一切全都是巨大的
red herring meanwhile the germans are thinking about grey's mediation proposal so that has got back to the kaiser the ambassador's reporter the kaiser does not like it at all the kaiser scribbles on it on the piece of paper he says it's's useless, it's nonsense, it's a complete waste of time. And he says, why would we betray our one friend in Europe, Austria, who we've promised that we would back? Why would we suddenly say, well, actually, I think we should all have a bit of a mediation? You know, it's that classic thing of, I don't know, it's people who've fallen out, and one friend says, I'll stand by you no matter what.
烟雾弹。与此同时，德国人正在考虑格雷的调停提议。消息已经传回了德皇那里，大使们进行了汇报，德皇一点也不喜欢这个提议。德皇在那张纸上乱涂乱改，他写道：这毫无用处，纯属无稽之谈，完全是在浪费时间。他说，我们为什么要背叛我们在欧洲唯一的盟友奥地利？我们已经答应过要支持他们的。我们为什么要突然说，嗯，实际上，我想我们都应该进行一点调停？你知道，这就是那种典型的……我不知道，有些人闹翻了，其中一个朋友说，无论发生什么我都站在你这边。
Never give in to those miscreants down the road or whatever. And then the next day he says, actually, I was thinking I might organise a meeting in a cafe and we can all talk. But what? Are you on my side or not? Kaiser thinks, you can't do that to your friend. I think you're revealing details about your school days there, Dominic. Really? I'm a hold firm man, Tom.
永远不要向街那头的那些无赖屈服，诸如此类。然后第二天他说，实际上，我在想我或许可以组织一场咖啡馆会议，我们可以坐下来谈谈。但是，什么？你到底是站在我这边还是不站在我这边？德皇心想，你怎么能这样对你的朋友。我觉得你在这里泄露了你学生时代的细节，多米尼克。真的吗？我是个立场坚定的人，汤姆。
What could possibly go wrong? What's the worst that could happen? Just a shame that your hand wasn't on the tiller of the ship of state in 1914. Exactly. Well, I wouldn't be off fishing, that's for sure, like some people. I wouldn't be fishing with fox murdering loins. To be fair, Edward Grey wasn't either. No, he wasn't.
究竟能出什么岔子呢？最坏的结果能有多糟？只可惜在1914年，你的手没有握住国家这艘大船的舵。没错。好吧，我至少不会去钓鱼，那是肯定的，不像某些人。我也不会和虐狐的律师去钓鱼。公平地说，爱德华·格雷也没有。不，他没有。
He was on his own, wasn't he? Melancholy, thinking about his wife and real tennis. So the Germans at this point, we're on the Saturday. The Germans still do not think that there will be a world war and we know this we can be pretty certain because people in the foreign office are giving off-the-record interviews to Berlin newspapers Gottlieb Van Jagoff who is the foreign minister is talking to the editor of the Berliner Tigerblatt and he is saying maybe war will come one day with Russia and we must be firm, but it probably won't
他是独自一人，不是吗？带着忧郁，想着他的妻子和真网球。所以此时的德国人——我们是在星期六。德国人仍然不认为会爆发世界大战，我们知道这一点，我们可以相当确信，因为外交部的人正在向柏林报纸提供非正式采访。外交大臣戈特利布·冯·雅戈夫正在同《柏林日报》的主编交谈，他说，或许有一天会与俄罗斯爆发战争，我们必须坚定立场，但大概不会是
be today. His political director says the same thing. The Russians, they'll just shout loudly and hot days will follow, but that will be it. And if you're going to be critical of the Germans, as a lot of historians are, you would say at this point, they are just being willfully reckless and self-deluding. Again, it's the intelligence failure. They just don't understand how seriously the Russians are taking all this. Now, there are some people, particularly, I mean, there are people in the foreign office in London, some of Grey's mandarins, who are a little bit more hard-nosed about this. And the classic example of this is a man, an absolutely bizarre man, he has a ridiculous
今天。他的政治主管也说了同样的话。俄罗斯人，他们只会大喊大叫，接着会迎来几天的热浪，但也就仅此而已。如果你要批评德国人，正如许多历史学家所做的那样，你会说此时此刻，他们简直是在肆意妄为、自欺欺人。这依然是情报失败。他们根本不明白俄罗斯人对此事的态度有多么严肃。现在，有些人，特别是……我的意思是，伦敦外交部里有一些人，格雷的一些高级文官，他们对此态度更加务实强硬。最典型的例子就是一个人，一个绝对怪异的人，他甚至有一个荒谬的
name, actually. What would you even call him, Tom? Sir Air Crow? Yeah, Sir Air Crow. Yeah. Now, he is the chief German? Yeah, Sir Air Crow. Yeah. Now, he is the chief Germanophobe at the British Foreign Office. Despite basically being German. Despite being German himself, which is bonkers.
名字。你到底该怎么叫他，汤姆？厄尔·克罗爵士？是的，厄尔·克罗爵士。是的。现在，他是主要的反德派？是的，厄尔·克罗爵士。是的。现在，他是英国外交部的首席反德派。尽管他基本上是个德国人。尽管他自己就是个德国人，这太疯狂了。
So he was born in Leipzig, educated in Dusseldorf and Berlin. He first came to Britain when he was 17 to cram for the foreign office exam. And he spoke with a German accent. One of his parents was British, which is how he qualified. And he is fanatically anti-German. You've got to believe there's some strange psychological. Yeah, kind of Oedipal complex or something. Yeah, exactly.
所以他出生在莱比锡，在杜塞尔多夫和柏林受教育。他17岁时第一次来到英国，为外交部考试做突击冲刺。他说话带着德国口音。他的父母中有一位是英国人，这就是他获得资格的原因。他狂热地反德。你不得不相信这其中存在某种奇怪的心理因素。是的，某种俄狄浦斯情结之类的东西。是的，完全正确。
And he has been saying since 1907, Germany is a bully and a brat. It's the new boy. It's the bullying boy at school. Bullies only respect strength. It's reminiscent of Kipling's poem on Dengeld, isn't it? Yes. That, you know, you mustn't pay at all.
而且他自1907年以来一直说，德国是个恶霸和小混混。它是新来的。它是学校里那个盛气凌人的男孩。恶霸只尊重力量。这让人想起吉卜林关于“丹麦金”的诗，不是吗？是的。那就是，你绝不能付钱。
You'll never get rid of the Dane. Yeah. We never pay anyone Dengeld. Yeah. So this weekend, Saturday the 25th of July, he writes a memo to Gray that you will see cited in every single book about this because it really does sum up the dilemma for Britain. He says, if there's war, he thinks there will be a war because he says, I think the Germans really do want to take over the world
你永远摆脱不了丹麦人。是的。我们从不向任何人支付丹麦金。是的。所以这个周末，7月25日星期六，他给格雷写了一份备忘录，你会发现每一本关于这段历史的书都会引用它，因为它确实概括了英国的困境。他说，如果有战争——他认为会有一场战争，因为他说，我认为德国人确实想统治世界，
because he hates Germany so much. And he says, if we stay out of this war, there are two alternatives. Number one is the Germans and the Austrians win. And in that case, they will dominate Europe. They will dominate the channel ports, all of that kind of thing. Our allies would have been crushed and we'll be left alone and friendless at the mercy of the Prussians. That's number one. And he says, number two is the other possibility, probably less likely, the French and the Russians win. And he says,
因为他太痛恨德国了。他说，如果我们置身于这场战争之外，有两种可能。第一种是德国人和奥地利人赢了。那样的话，他们将称霸欧洲。他们将控制海峡港口，诸如此类的事情。我们的盟友将被击溃，而我们将孤立无援、没有朋友，任由普鲁士人宰割。这是第一种。然后他说，第二种是另一种可能性，或许可能性较小，那就是法国和俄罗斯赢了。他说，
what would they make of us then? Because they would have won without us and they would despise us for not having helped them. And then they would turn on us. They would drive us out of the Mediterranean. They would drive us out of India. We would lose everything. And so Crow says to Gray, stop deluding yourself about your mediation and all that rubbish. We should get stuck in. We have no choice. Our own policy has left us the logic of our policy. There is no debate to be had. We should get cracking on fighting, which is obviously not what Gray wants to do. So presumably Gray is hoping that the Serbs will maybe back down
那他们会怎么看待我们呢？因为他们是在没有我们的帮助下赢的，他们会鄙视我们没有帮他们。然后他们会把矛头转向我们。他们会把我们赶出地中海。他们会把我们赶出印度。我们将失去一切。所以克罗对格雷说，别再对你的调停和那些垃圾自我欺骗了。我们应该卷入其中。我们别无选择。我们自己的政策让我们走到了这一步——这是我们政策的逻辑。没有什么好争论的。我们应该开始动手战斗，这显然不是格雷想做的。所以大概格雷是希望塞尔维亚人也许会退让，
and that the whole crisis will go away? Yeah, maybe. Or that they will respond to the ultimatum in such a way that there'll be a fudge, maybe? Now, actually, let's move the focus back to Serbia. So Saturday is the day the ultimatum expires. What have they been up to? First of all, they've been making some limited military preparations. They've put the army in charge
然后整个危机就会烟消云散？是的，也许吧。或者他们对最后通牒的回应会产生某种折中方案，也许吧？现在，实际上，让我们把焦点转回塞尔维亚。星期六是最后通牒到期的日子。他们一直在忙些什么？首先，他们一直在做一些有限的军事准备。他们把铁路交由
of their railways. They've started to bomb some of the bridges. Well, let's just remind people, Belgrade is next to the river that constitutes the frontier with Austro-Hungarian Empire. There's two rivers actually, because the border was so different in those days, that affected the frontier, the Danube and the River Sava. So they are making preparations there. All day, they've been working on a reply to the ultimatum. It's one of the most famous diplomatic documents in history, and it is covered with crossings out and scribbles because they keep changing their mind about what exactly to say,
军队管理。他们开始炸毁一些桥梁。好吧，让我们提醒大家，贝尔格莱德紧邻着构成奥匈帝国边境的河流。实际上有两条河，因为那时的边界大不相同，这影响了国界，即多瑙河和萨瓦河。所以他们在那里做准备。一整天，他们都在起草对最后通牒的回复。这是历史上最著名的外交文件之一，上面涂满了划掉的痕迹和乱七八糟的涂鸦，因为他们一直在改变主意，不知道到底该说些什么，
and they're in a terrible panic. The typewriter is jammed, so they're having to adjust it by hand. It's all a total shambles. One of the key men who's drafting the reply is the trade minister, who's called Velizar Jankovic. And on his mind all that day is the fact that, I mean, this tells you everything, I guess, about that kind of globalized pre-1914 world. His wife and children are on holiday in Austria-Hungary. They're on the Adriatic coast. They're in Croatia. So many people go to Croatia every year. Well, they're there. Because it's famous. This is an age where you don't need passports, right? Unless you're going to Russia.
而且他们陷入了极度的恐慌。打字机卡壳了，所以他们不得不亲手调整。这一切简直是一团糟。起草回复的关键人物之一是贸易大臣维利扎尔·扬科维奇。那一整天，他的脑子里都在盘算着一件事——我想这说明了一切，关于那个1914年之前的全球化世界。他的妻子和孩子正在奥匈帝国度假。他们在亚得里亚海海岸。他们在克罗地亚。每年有那么多人去克罗地亚。好吧，他们就在那儿。因为那里很有名。这是一个不需要护照的时代，对吧？除非你要去俄罗斯。
You can just go anywhere. Right. Exactly. Exactly. And if you're in Serbia, the Dalmatian coast is exactly where you would go, you know, sunning yourself in Dubrovnik or whatever. And he says, oh my God, if the ultimatum expires and war comes, they will be trapped. And he decides, this is an amazing story.
你可以去任何地方。对。完全正确。如果你在塞尔维亚，达尔马提亚海岸正是你会去的地方，你知道的，在杜布罗夫尼克沐浴阳光或诸如此类。他说，天哪，如果最后通牒到期，战争爆发，他们就会被困住。他决定——这是一个了不起的故事。
He decides, I have to go to the German ambassador, ask him for help to get my family out. And he says to his coachman, take me to the German embassy. But in the general air of panic, and of course, Austria is on everybody's minds, the coachman goes to the wrong embassy. So he arrives at the Austrian embassy at five o'clock. The ultimatum expires at six. So the Austrian ambassador is waiting for a Serbian visitor. So he assumes this guy has come with the ultimatum. Yeah. Yankovic gets out and he's like, oh, they've sent the trade minister. And Yankovic, there's a terrible realization he's come to the wrong place. And the Austrian ambassador is right there by the carriage saying, please step inside. So he steps in and then he says, I've actually
他决定，我必须去找德国大使，请他帮忙把我的家人弄出来。他对马车夫说，带我去德国大使馆。但在普遍的恐慌气氛中，当然，每个人脑子里都想着奥地利，马车夫却把车开到了错误的大使馆。所以他在五点钟抵达了奥地利大使馆。最后通牒在六点到期。所以奥地利大使正在等待一个塞尔维亚访客。因此他以为这家伙是带着最后通牒来的。是的。扬科维奇下车后心想，哦，他们把贸易大臣派来了。扬科维奇突然意识到自己走错了地方。而奥地利大使就站在马车旁说，请进请进。所以他走了进去，然后他说，我其实
come about a very embarrassing and awkward situation. And he explains, you know, if our countries are at war, my wife and children are on the wrong side of the border. Well, he's basically giving away what the Serbs are going to do by saying that, isn't he? Yes, exactly. And Baron Giesel responds splendidly. He says, again, I think the voice you're looking for here is an Austrian Roger Moore or sort of George Sanders.
是为了一个非常尴尬和窘迫的情况而来的。他解释说，你知道的，如果我们的国家处于战争状态，我的妻子和孩子就在国境的错误一侧。好吧，他这么说基本上是把塞尔维亚人打算怎么做给泄露出来了，不是吗？是的，完全正确。吉泽尔男爵做出了精彩的回应。他说——再次说明，我想你在这里寻找的嗓音是一个奥地利的罗杰·摩尔或某种乔治·桑德斯。
Christopher Plummer in The Sound of Music. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, that. Yeah. That's exactly. He says, it will be my pleasure as a gentleman to see to it that your family have special passports to take them to Venice and our government will give them 10 gold Napoleon so they are not out of pocket. Do you know, Dominic, I know that this is the most disastrous failure of diplomacy in
《音乐之声》里的克里斯托弗·普卢默。是的，绝对的。对，就是那个。对。就是这样。他说，作为一名绅士，我很高兴能确保您的家人拥有特殊的护照，带他们前往威尼斯，我们政府会给他们10枚拿破仑金币，这样他们就不会手头拮据了。你知道吗，多米尼克，我知道这是历史上最灾难性的外交失败。
global history. Yeah. But weirdly, I think diplomats are coming out very well from this story. They're making lots of mistakes. I think it's fair to say. Yeah. But they're all tremendous chaps. They're all tremendous history. Yeah. But weirdly, I think diplomats are coming out very well from this story. They're making lots of mistakes. It's fair to say. Yeah. But they're all tremendous chaps. They were tremendous fellows.
全球历史。是的。但奇怪的是，我觉得外交官在这场故事里表现得非常不错。他们犯了很多错误。我觉得可以这么说。是的。但他们全都是了不起的家伙。他们全都是了不起的历史人物。是的。但奇怪的是，我觉得外交官在这场故事里表现得非常不错。他们犯了很多错误。可以这么说。是的。但他们全都是了不起的家伙。他们都是了不起的伙伴。
Yeah. You'd love to have a dinner party with them, wouldn't you? You really would. Baron Giesel, Prince Lichnowsky, all these characters. Probably not the French guy because, you know, I don't want to see his translator. So as Yankovic leaves, it occurs to him the Baron is in his traveling clothes. He's wearing plus fours. Everything is packed up, ready to go, ready for war. And he realizes, you know, there is no way
是的。你很愿意和他们共进晚餐，不是吗？你真的会的。吉泽尔男爵、利希诺夫斯基亲王，所有这些角色。大概不是那个法国人，因为，你知道的，我不想见到他的翻译。当扬科维奇离开时，他突然发现这位男爵穿着旅行服装。他穿着加长四分之三裤。一切都打包好了，准备出发，为战争做好了准备。他意识到，
the Austrians are not going to fight. And indeed, with five minutes to go until the deadline, 5.55, the Prime Minister Nikola Pasich arrives at the Austrian legation. Giesel shows him into the study and Pasich says, part of your demands we have accepted. For the rest, we place our hope in the loyalty and chivalry of an Austrian general. And he gives him the reply to the note. And to cut a long story short, the reply to the note, it's often misconstrued. People say the Serbs accepted all the demands except the most inflammatory number six. That's actually not right. And that's the one where the Habsburgs demand the right to join the investigation on Serbian soil. But that's not right. They accepted all the demands in theory but not in practice. With caveats. There were always caveats. They said well we don't think
奥地利人绝不可能不打仗。事实上，距离最后期限还有五分钟，即5点55分，首相尼古拉·帕希奇抵达了奥地利公使馆。吉泽尔把他领进书房，帕希奇说，你们的一部分要求我们已经接受了。至于其余部分，我们寄希望于一位奥地利将军的忠诚和骑士精神。然后他把对照会的回复交给了他。长话短说，对照会的回复，人们经常误解它。人们说塞尔维亚人接受了所有的要求，除了最具煽动性的第六条。这其实是不对的。哈布斯堡王朝要求有权参与在塞尔维亚领土上的调查的就是那一条。但这不对。他们在理论上接受了所有要求，但在实践中没有。带有附加条件的。总是有附加条件的。他们说，嗯，我们认为
this nationalist organization even exists but if you can prove it exists we'll help you to shut it down. Or they say yes we will do this insofar as it is commensurate with international law. So when Giesel looks at the document he says i mean he wrote later nearly all our demands were twisted robbed of their meaning and purpose and their fulfillment if not directly refused was so hedged in reservations that it was in practice useless and all diplomatic historians by the way this isn't an anti-serbian thing all diplomatic historians have said it was a brilliantly, brilliantly written reply that basically gave the Austrians, seemed to give them almost everything, but in reality gave them absolutely nothing. And Giesel reads it and he says, fine, it's absolutely clear.
这个民族主义组织甚至不存在，但如果你能证明它存在，我们会帮你取缔它。或者他们说，是的，我们会在符合国际法的范围内这样做。所以当吉泽尔看着这份文件时，他说——他后来写道，我们几乎所有的要求都被歪曲了、被剥夺了原本的含义和目的，其履行即使没有被直接拒绝，也布满了各种保留条件，以至于在实践中毫无用处。而且顺便说一句，所有的外交史学家——这并不是针对塞尔维亚的偏见——所有外交史学家都说过，这是一份极其精妙、极其高明起草的回复，它基本上给了奥地利人……似乎给了他们几乎一切，但在现实中什么也没给他们。吉泽尔读了读，然后说，好吧，这下绝对一清二楚了。
He said, I had nothing to weigh, nothing to decide. All there was to do was to leave. So he burns the ciphers. He literally locks the embassy and gives the key to the Germans. Please look after the embassy. And then he goes to the station. And you were saying about diplomats, Tom, all the other diplomats, all the other ambassadors have assembled at the station to see him off, waving their top hats and stuff, except for the Russians. And I suppose you'd say understandably, the French, I think they could have tried. And the Romanians who were
他说，我无须权衡，也无须决断。唯一要做的就是离开。于是他烧毁了密码。他锁上大使馆的大门，把钥匙交给了德国人，请他们代为照看大使馆。然后他去了火车站。汤姆，正如你刚才所说，所有其他的外交官和大使都在火车站为他送行，挥舞着大礼帽等等，除了俄国人。我想你可以理解，法国人本应该也可以去试试。还有罗马尼亚人
trying to get into bed with the Russians and the French, I think they could have made a showing as well. I think that was poor. Well, I'm afraid that reflects badly on all three. All three, exactly. You were saying how close it is. It took him 10 minutes to get the train and then to cross the bridge into Austrian territory. That's how close they are. The news reaches Vienna very quickly, of course. And there are huge crowds outside the war ministry. There are people singing patriotic songs. They're singing this famous anthem about the siege of Belgrade in 1717. They're waving flags, great crowds of students. You know, we should sacrifice everything for our emperor. There is genuine excitement in Austria.
他们当时正试图和俄国人、法国人套近乎，我认为他们本也应该表现一下。我觉得他们的做法太糟糕了。嗯，恐怕这让这三方都很没面子。确实如此，完全没错。正如你所说，两地离得有多近。他只花了10分钟就坐上火车，然后穿过大桥进入奥地利领土。他们就是这么近。消息当然很快传到了维也纳。战争部外面聚集了巨大的人群。人们唱着爱国歌曲，唱着那首关于1717年贝尔格莱德之围的著名赞美诗。他们挥舞着旗帜，大批学生聚集在一起。你知道的，我们应该为我们的皇帝牺牲一切。奥地利上下充满了真实的狂热。
And this is what gives people the sense that everyone greeted the war with great enthusiasm. Yeah. But it's kind of surface froth to a degree, isn't it? It's surface. And of course, don't forget the Austrians, they think they're only fighting Serbia. I mean, as it happens, their campaign to Serbia is a total disaster. But it's a slightly different issue, a small Balkan war. And they're not celebrating a world war. They're celebrating revenge for their archduke as they sit. However, there is one person who doesn't react in quite that way. The Emperor Franz Joseph is in Bad isch on the lakeside at his summer house with count berchtold the foreign minister and they're waiting
而正是这种现象，让人觉得所有人都是满腔热情地迎接着战争的到来。是的。但在某种程度上，这只是一种表面的泡沫，不是吗？只是表面现象。当然，别忘了奥地利人当时以为他们只是在和塞尔维亚打仗。我的意思是，碰巧的是，他们对塞尔维亚的军事行动是一场彻底的灾难。但这其实是另一个稍有不同的问题，一场小规模的巴尔干战争。他们庆祝的不是一场世界大战，正如他们所想的那样，他们是在为他们的皇储复仇。然而，有一个人的反应却完全不同。奥地利皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫正在巴德伊舍湖畔的避暑别墅里，与外交大臣贝希特尔多夫伯爵在一起，他们正在等待
for the news and an aide comes in to tell franz joseph the news and says the ultimatum expired you know relations have been severed whatever and franz joseph just is totally quiet and still and he just says also doch well then there it is and there it is the states of europe tethered together by a mountaineer as rope getting ready to vanish over the precipice into the abyss dominic of war so um if you want to follow that we have two more episodes of this series to go and they'll be out in due course but if you want to hear them straight away you can of course get those last two episodes right now by joining the rest is history club at the rest is history.com or accessing it immediately if you're already a member of the
消息。一名随从进来向弗朗茨·约瑟夫汇报消息，说最后通牒已经过期，你知道的，外交关系已经断绝之类的。弗朗茨·约瑟夫完全沉默、一动不动，他只是说道："好吧，既然如此。"事情就这样发生了，欧洲各国就像被登山绳索系在一起一样，准备好一起跌落深渊，坠入战争的万丈深渊。多米尼克，关于战争……所以，如果您想继续关注，我们这个系列还有两集，将会在适的时候发布。但如果您想马上收听，当然可以通过加入"历史余韵"俱乐部（therestisushistory.com）立即获取最后两集，如果您已经是该俱乐部的会员，也可以直接收听
rest is history club either way we'll be back with the final two episodes in the series very soon bye-bye. Bye-bye. back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“历史余韵”俱乐部无论如何，我们很快就会带着本系列的最后两集回来，再见。再见。为您揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想收听无广告的音频、收看独家加更节目并优先获得现场演出门票，请前往该网址。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。